savez vous que ce sont des moines qui
ont raconté les aventures de goupil à
l'origine il s'agissait de contes et de
poèmes en latin que pierre de saint
cloud traduisit en langage populaire le
roman si le roman de renart montre des
personnages aux prises avec la lutte
pour la vie si l'état fidèle reflet des
coutumes de la fin du xiième siècle il
n'en reste pas moins avant tout un
divertissement mais silence on tourne
nous allons vous conter l'histoire des
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures de
or dans run à ce jour là
[Musique]
oncle
m
ma
que t'arrive-t-il tu me semble en bien
mauvais points n'aurais tu pas de génie
non justement
mais elle n'en est même pas envie que me
chante tu là d'un versant venez donc
préparé pour renard une de ces
brochettes de rognons dont vous avez le
secret voici trois beaux jambon que vous
ne devriez pas exposer ainsi si la le
vos voisins les voiliers l'embrassa par
un conseil d'état chez les sans perdre
un instant et aller crier partout quand
vous les a volés
bon je ne suis pas inquiet sur leur sort
sinon vous en demandez vous refuseriez
absolument
à bientôt
vos brochettes été excellent
[Musique]
oh
où
3au gère mes jambes et mes chers gendre
disparu au volant au secours aux voleurs
qu'avez-vous à crier ainsi au au nord
mais jean baud on me les a pris bravo je
vois que vous suivez mes conseils il
faut aller aussi le crier dans le
village que vos voisins le sache bien
mais au nord c'est la vérité on m'a volé
mes jambes on dit toujours on dit
toujours me enfin puisque je vous
rappelle
oh
[Musique]
mais je ne me trompe pas c'est hier
seule main que dieu vous protège vous
est l'âme de votre père en quelle fameux
chanteur c'était le meilleur chanteur de
france partie mais vous même il me
semble vous faisiez de la musique le
plaisir que j'ai à vous rencontrer se
doublerait si vous consentiez à me
chanter une petite ritournelle à comment
trouvez vous cela
prenez pas mal pas mal mais ne pouvait
vous monter plus haut
ouais assez jolie en effet continuer
continuer je vous en prie quoi
[Applaudissements]
seulement je pouvais réunir 1 mm repas
le fromage et le chanteur
votre fromage qui vient de tomber
m'apporte une odeur insupportable et moi
qui me suis rompu la jambe dans un
maudit piège non loin d'ici je ne puis
le déplacer chercheurs seul un je vous
en prie descendez me délivrer de cette
abomination
hâtez vous mon cher
n'ayez rien à craindre de moi qui suis
impotent
un traître j'aurais dû m'en douter et
bien garde de ce fromage je te
l'abandonnent
[Musique]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
en
[Musique]
et
regardons là au milieu de la route
je ne prends pas c'est un blaireau
ou à goop il
descendons
avant qu'il ne lui échappe
[Musique]
et il le fera plus de mal
nous n'avions pas besoin de nous presser
jolie police qui vont bien quatre livres
les regarde donc cette gorge fourni moi
je dirai au moins 100 livres
[Musique]
bonne journée déjà la pêche qui avait
été excellente il ne faudra pas tarder à
préparer cette belle fourrure cause
toujours mon homme ma peau n'est point
encore prête à sécher
[Musique]
non
bon
[Musique]
goupil goupil en groupe et en groupe ils
vont gober
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
oh
[Rires]
où
on
[Musique]
oui mon père je vous apporte des
nouvelles
ouvrez mois
rémois dos je vous dis ce sont
d'excellentes nouvelles et nous noie ils
ont grand voyou je vous avais pris pour
un voleur
attendez au moins que les frères soit
levé de table
il aurait il des moines venus chez vous
bien sûr ce sont ceux de l'abbaye de
diront ils m'ont fait la grâce de me
recevoir dans leur ordre ouvre moi
je voulais avoir de tes nouvelles j'ai
grand fleuve du ces
serait ce de l'avion que vous préparez
ainsi que non la religion interdit
ce sont de gros et gras poisson ce sera
nouveau pour moi mais veux tu as accordé
le gîte pour cette nuit mais la has pour
rentrer il faut être ordonné moine
vous n'êtes pas passer notre chemin
[Musique]
[Rires]
donne moi donc un meursault beauté bien
sûr voilà de la part de nos frères dans
l'espoir que vous serez bientôt d'un
autre excellent qu'elle dit je me sens
tout près de la conversion puis-je en
avoir un souvent il ne tient qu'à vous
quand vous aurez passé la robe vous en
aurez autant que voudrait alors d'accord
fais-moi raser le crâne
[Musique]
passez votre tête par le pertuis que je
vous fasse votre couronne
oh
oh oh oh no oh oh oh oh no oh la la
[Musique]
oh
en
on
ici vous trouverez de quoi passer noël
le ventre plein il suffit de plonger le
saut dans le dos lorsqu'il devient lourd
c'est qu'il est garnie de nourriture
[Musique]
tron
dit comment je dois m'y prendre très
simple comme ceci
conte
comment
à présent attendez une heure ou deux
vous ne tarderez pas à sentir le saut se
remplir de poisson j'aurai la patience
d'attendre renard
[Musique]
il
en
[Musique]
il me semble que mme haacke s'alourdit
la pêche sera excellente
il ya déjà pompe voyons c'est le moment
on secoure honneur je t'en prie le
poisson quand je ne puis les soulever
vite venez
[Musique]
comme un vous êtes encore là prenez vos
poissons et partez voyons je n'ai pas la
force de soulever le saut écoutez ce
sont les chiens qu'on appelle le grain
de ne pouvoir rien faire pour vous
[Musique]
come on
excellent
ils sont excellents séduit
où pourrait-on en trouver d'autres car
ceux ci nous pas réussi à apaiser ma
flux rien de plus facile
vous voyez la basse et amis alors nous
trouverons là autant de biscuits que
nouveau grand
[Musique]
mon
non
[Musique]
où
non
maison non plus on a envie d'en manger
mais qu'y at il donc dans cette tenue
[Musique]
je soit loué
à
vous buvez un trop petit coup ce n'est
pas digne de vous
comment
mais je n'arrête pas
sosh que je puis boire plus que toi
[Musique]
renard
si nous allions chanter
à l'auteur
[Musique]
renard à présent que je suis prête
je veux
sonné les cloches
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
non
oh
devant l'échec de brens l'ours et de
tibère le chat noble le lion décide
d'envoyer grimbert le blaireau à
maupertuis gravers le blaireau étant le
cousin de renard il avait toute chance
de réussir à le ramener à la cour à ger
grain vais rentrer vite
quel grand plaisir et entrevoir écouter
- renard vos malisse ont poussé tout le
monde à bout je suis chargé par le roi
de vous porter la troisième semaine
[Musique]
vous devez vous présenter à la cour
hélas le conserver aucun espoir
vous serez condamné à la peine capitale
lisez cette lettre portant laisser les
royaux vous jugerez de la gravité de la
situation
mais sur noble le lion souverain maître
de toutes les régions et de tous les
animaux du monde mandat renard on est
derniers supplice s'il ne vient demain
répondre à la clameur élevé contre lui
dans ma cour
il devra se munir de la corde pour le
pendre
à grimbert conseillez moi
que dois-je faire pour ne pas être
pendus hélas personne ne viendra m'aider
à vous défendre
mettez donc un profil peu de temps qui
vous reste qu'on fait c'est vous à
défaut de prêtres je vous écouterez je
me repens d'avoir fait trop de mal à
yang
je ne puis me rappeler tous les autres
tours que j'ai joué les personnes à la
cour du roi ne peut se plaindre de moi
je ne parle pas bien sûr des pôles des
paysans de brun et du miel de tibère et
des souris de tout cela je bats ma
coulpe et je veux faire pénitents renard
vous vous êtes bien confessé prométhée à
présent de ne plus recommencer
je le promets
[Musique]
oh
gardez ce chapeau aux abonnés vous avez
ici des provisions pour de longues
années
je vous recommande a lieu est prié le
pot qu'il me laisse revenir bientôt
ainsi s'achève notre histoire provisoire
je suis pour
en grimpeur
en
mongeau
la mission de brun et y en a des choux
et ses divers le chat qui est chargé à
son tour par le roi de ramener renard à
la cour
[Musique]
renard êtes vous là répondez-moi
bienvenue thibert ne m'en voulez pas
renhar pour la mission dont je suis
chargé je viens dans la part du roi
chaque gens à la cour se plaint de vous
le roi menace seul votre cousin dans un
bear le blaireau et votre défenseur les
menaces ne tue pas
j'irai à la cour et j'y verrais bien
qu'ils portent plainte contre moi ce
sera sage renard et je vous le conseille
en ami je me suis pressé dans ma mission
je m'aperçois que je meurs de faim
[Musique]
n'auriez-vous pas quelque chose à manger
hélas ce tout ce que je pourrai vous
trouvez ce serait quelques rats ou
souris comment des sourires mais vous
savez que je ne me nourrir est pas donc
rosso dans ce cas vous n'avez qu'à me
suivre
[Musique]
yvon c'est le prêtre sont éloignés et
bien fourni en formant et en avoine les
souris s'en donnent à coeur joie
[Musique]
voici le trou par où il faut entrer
passé et régalez vous
[Musique]
l'abonné renard et prix venait
te voilà neuf ans tu me laisses seul son
avertir que la trouille avait été
rebouché tu m'as trahi à bay hill en
gras ce n'est pas moi qui n'ai rebouché
c'est ce méchant prêtre moi aussi j'ai
dû fuir sous ces menaces mais je vous
attendais inquiet sous ce chêne si nous
allions vendre ses habits à la fois
bonnes idées mon compère
yeves garden seigneur vous aussi mon
père
d'où venez vous ainsi nous sommes des
marchands nous allons à la foire nous
fournissons les chanoines de l'église
toute proche
mais bien sûr nous pourrions vous donner
la préférence
combien moment des vous aime bien et
j'irai droit au but donnez moi c'est toi
et nous habitons pas vous le marché me
semble honnête c'est d'accord
[Musique]
dommage que nous n'ayons pas une
deuxième mois car tu n'es pas aussi bien
partagée que moi voulez vous dire que
vous gardez loi pour vous tout seul
ce serait une bien mauvaise action
ysengrin
[Musique]
je n'ai pas besoin de serment si tu
souffres de la fin tu trouvera de quoi
l'apaiser dans ce bois
[Musique]
[Musique]
on
ans
quand on tue au bord de cette route une
charrette remplie de harengs biafrais
comme on le sait tu je les ai aperçus à
une lieue de là j'ai couru et me suis
posté ici je vais m'étendre sur la route
en faisant le mort les marchands de
poissons lorsqu'il arrive on prenne mois
a ravi d'avoir une peau à si bon compte
me jetteront dans leur s'arrête là
j'aurais tout mon temps pour me remplir
le ventre de leur pêche
une fois repu ne me restera plus qu'à
sauter à terre et par saint leu voilà
une excellente idée ne voudrais tu pas
me laisser tenter ma chance je suis
d'accord pour vous laisser ma place mais
à une seule condition c'est que dans
cette affaire vous n'oubliez pas et que
vous emporter quelqu'un rang pour moi ce
premier ronald denis nous a si justement
la charrette qui approche j'entends le
bruit des roues allongez-vous vite
[Musique]
on
à
regarde d'abord on dirait un loup
ouais il a l'air bien mort attendez voir
[Musique]
à
l'idée qu'il fait semblant et qu'il veut
nous jouer le même tour que ce maudit
groupe id tu vois bien qu'il est mort
il est bien mort je te dis
attends à peu tu vas voir
[Musique]
en
où
rumeurs de fin renard ne m'as-tu pas dit
que tu connaissais un autre moyen de
trouver de la nourriture
bien sûr il y à tous prennent ici une
maison qui satisfera nos désirs elle
appartient un paysan qui possède trois
bojan bon je sais comment s'y introduire
et si vous voulez me suivre je peux vous
y conduire sur le veut mais je meurs
d'impatience d'être devancé boerenbond
alors partons
[Musique]
le
voyez heureux vous allez pouvoir apaiser
votre femme
[Musique]
il faut se hâter ysengrin on peut nous
surprendre
je suis prêt mais on la veut je crois
avoir trop mangé
qu'est ce qui ne va pas vous nuire au
passé vous voulez rire mais je te dis
que je suis coincé
elles ont essayé encore
[Musique]
attendez nous allons essayer un autre
moyen
[Musique]
allons encore un effort et oui
maintenant
[Musique]
au secours
savez vous que je connais au delà de
cette règle ferme l'enclos une troupe
doit bien grasse elle pourrait
facilement être à nous peut-être
est-elle bien gardés au juste par un
paysan j'ai couru vite et si je peux
leur apporter une ou deux nous pourrons
cette fois allé manger ensemble
[Musique]
cette fois c'en est trop renard voilà
assez longtemps que tu te moques de moi
tu comptais bien sûr le sien pour me
faire déchirer sa chemise angle vous
savez bien vous êtes le plus fort n'en
abusez pas kg à me plaindre au roi
et puis si vous me tuez vous serez jugés
et condamnés à mort
ysengrin avant de mourir
recevez ma dernière confession je jure
que je n'ai jamais cherché à vous nuit
ici renard n'avait vraiment rien à se
reprocher bon je te laisse en vie
[Musique]
lève toi je te pardonne alors il faut
m'en faire serment comme tous vos droits
je suis prêt à le jurer sur les saintes
reliques ben harper venait avec moi je
connais une église non loin d'ici un
saint martin repose près du porche vous
pourrez faire votre serment sur sa tombe
au nom de tous les bienheureux de celui
qui reposent ici je jure de ne garder
aucun ressentiment envers renard or bien
il en passant par là
on joue au revoir au revoir à prix très
doux par les contraintes à penser nuit
un parjure
le sainte a puni
est ibère ne courait pas si vite
vous savez que je suis votre ami en
vérité mon cher thibert le monde est
bien méchant la charité n'existe plus
chacun cherche à tromper l'autre
l'important est d'avoir un véritable ami
vous par exemple 10 mai est ce vrai
renard
absolument je me sens pour vous une
grande affection
[Musique]
oh
j'en ai ma part renard sur ne sommes
nous pas amis mais nous devons tous
partager alors partageons des mangeons
[Musique]
ce mieux ne me semble pas assez à les
cas mieux vaut l'emporter ailleurs dans
un endroit où ne seront plus tranquilles
parfait
comment porter vous donc ces andouilles
regardez les deux bouts qui traînent
dans la poussière
moi je les porterai autrement et comment
cela
[Musique]
et moi thibert pas si vite
tibère pourquoi êtes-vous monté si haut
montée et nous mangerons ensemble et
comment le pourrait elle c'est à vous de
descendre je resterai ici jusqu'à ce que
vous descendiez même s'il faut être dans
nos sept ans je jure de ne pas quitter
cette paroisse avant que vous n'en
dessandier
[Musique]
non mais quelle échelle bruit
alors et votre serment l'avez vous déjà
oublié
[Musique]
quel bon vin vous amène pas ici je me
rende ce pas chez un paysan dont la
ferme se trouve à peu de distance sa
femme a placé dans sa poche un grand pot
de lait et j'aimerais bien en connaître
le goût venez avec moi renard si vous
voulez
je vous montrerai comment pénétrer dans
le love trouverait là de nombreux poulet
c'est avec plaisir que j'accepte tibet
[Musique]
oh
q
[Musique]
mieux vaut ne pas vous attaquer aux
poules maintenant car le pays andorre et
elles pourraient le réveiller allons à
la us d'abord nous reviendrons suite ici
vous croyez certains d'autant que le
chien ne tarderait pas à arriver
cela nuirait à mon expédition de la us
bonbons allons à la us
en
[Musique]
soulève le couvercle renard j'en
profiterai pour pénétrer à l'intérieur
[Musique]
bon ça suffit
tu as eu tout ce que tu voulais à
présent remonte car ce couvercle et
pesant
[Musique]
enfin toi je n'en peux plus
attendre encore un peu
je n'attends
[Musique]
au lieu de me maltraiter regarder
l'horizon grain voici une aventure qui
s'offre à nous ce beau jambes on nous
tue pas mieux que ma maigre et chine
bien sûr mais comme on la voir je vous
promets que vous aurez ce jambon et que
vous pourrez vous rassasier avec
[Musique]
mais je ne goûte guère les rencontres
avec les paysans elle se termine
toujours là coup de bâton laissez-moi
mener la verra bien
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'espère ysengrin que vous m'avez garder
la part qui me revient sur ce jambon tu
n'es pas sérieux au nord tu devrais
estimé bien heureux d'avoir échappé à
mon ressentiment
je te permet de prendre le bâton rien de
plus le bâton je crois bien que ce n'est
pas moi qui le méritent
[Musique]
les moines ne sont jamais dépourvu de
nourriture ils pourvoiront amandine et
carla ça ça a été mauvaise
[Musique]
au
en
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]
que vois-je la renault est ce possible
je fut naguère votre voisin et je vous
aimais bien je suis feu renard j'ai été
sage durant ma vie aujourd'hui je suis
très passé et je me trouve dans un lieu
de délices tu es donc mort et depuis
qu'on depuis deux jours
seriez vous disposé à changer vos
sentiments vers moi ma foi puisque tu es
mort je n'ai plus de jeunes
je regrette même que tu ne sois plus de
ce monde
et bien j'en ai grande joie parles-tu
sérieusement j'ai toute raison d'être
joyeux j'ai ici tout ce que je peux
désirer je ne vois que riche campagne
forêt verte grâce brebis chèvres et ânes
au autant de poulet que je désire
d'ailleurs si vous en voulez la preuve
il doit s'en trouver un sur le bord de
cette ouverture
le lait jeté comme superflus en sortant
demandé en effet st
l'armée tu dis vrai quel paradis que
celui où l'on peut manger autant à
attention il en gras le paradis on n'y
entre pas comme ça vous avez été violent
n'éloigne si vous vous croyez un état
d'espérer les oies du paradis et si
vraiment vous êtes repentant prenez le
vaisseau qui est près de vous et alors
vous descendrez doucement si votre
remords mais pas suffisant vous resterez
en haut je crois voir nos chances
tu vas tu ris irna
[Musique]
suis-je sur la bonne voie oui oui oui
vous y êtes
et je vous la laisse pour vous tous elle
[Musique]
on
c'est d'où vous venez vous étiez les
jours j'aurai il me semble bien des
reproches à vous faire
[Musique]
je crois que vous ne voulez rien faire
pour m créa
seriez vous pas plus galants avec l'état
[Musique]
madame c'est volontiers plus souvent que
je viendrai vous rendre visite mais
pourquoi dont il en grains matile priant
m
il prétend que j'ai certains penchant
pour vous
vraiment venir
[Musique]
il dit que je cherche à prendre sa place
ici
[Musique]
en
nous ne retrouverons ma belle
[Musique]
le
et
[Musique]
en
[Rires]
oh
en
m
[Musique]
les agissements de renards ont fini par
décider ysengrin le lot a demandé
justice auprès du noble lyon
leroy mandate aussitôt brin l'ours au
château de maupertuis afin de
réprimander renard
[Musique]
ans
en
[Musique]
ona je suis mais sachez du roi
forte et écouter son message au brun
vous n'auriez pas dû prendre cette peine
inutile
j'allais me rendre à la cour du roi dès
que j'aurai eu manger les excellents
mais que dame hermeline à préparer pour
moi un accusé ne doit-il pas prendre des
forces avant d'affronter la justice
j'ai dont ce matin passé en revue mais
provision de poids et de l'art et j'ai
déjeuné de plusieurs rayons d'un
excellent miel comment vous savez où se
procurait du miel ah ben si j'étais sûr
de trouver en vous un véritable ami je
vous donnerai autant de cet excellent
miel que vous pourriez en désirer il
n'aime pas bien loin
juste à l'entrée du bois gardés par le
forestier lanfroy mais ne venez-vous pas
ici un ennemi
assurément non horrible si peu confiance
en moi que craignez-vous jeu sert leroy
bien sûr mais je ne serai jamais dit
loyal bien
[Musique]
voilà ce que je vous ai promis la
réserve de miel est ici rentrer la tête
et prenez ce que vous voulez nous irons
bois ensuite
[Musique]
alors si embrun comment trouvez-vous mon
miel comme vous restez l'autre
voulez-vous tout garder pour vous sans
m'en laisser
[Musique]
allô allô loose
le vol a pris
[Musique]
e
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]